yeah welcome to a new video and it's a
Sicilian defense and it's a the rematch
now I just played down one game against
this challenger here and one with wide
and now we do the rematch here so we got
a Sicilian and he of course black got a
white choice um let's go for the fresh
new cover I'm not quite sure about pet
had played the sound on video yeah now
the normal move as be five but years ago
I very often played this Bishop e6 line
it's almost forgotten and probably it's
also worse than be five but it's not so
bad I mean can can play it it's not um
there's no known refutation or way for
y2 to gain a significant advantage you
have pretty quick development and you
don't you don't play b5 the cells got a
positive side and the negative side the
negative side very clearly is that the
night on 83 gets into play again but the
positivists you have haven't weakened
your green side it's also helpful in
some cases yeah in fact here Bishop f6
Queen f6 is technically a pawn sacrifice
wow this is very rarely very rarely
accepted this pawn and with with good
reason okay but I need to think briefly
why it's really Aegis that I had this on
the board I think it it was added up to
8
on 94 94 I could also be the reason it's
really not good to take the porn queen
g5 it's also a good move I hope dialogue
th first he goes Quincy five Quincy 525
Queenie to us it's not so good look the
eight Quincy five Queen g5 maybe Queen
III it's not that's not great but
certainly playable I can also try night
to d4 which doesn't look bad
okay I tried this I really forgot him
how how to how to play this I completely
forgot that he's may be able to play
long castles okay didn't do it here
intended Queen to g5 I had um I didn't
calculate this completely but my idea
was if he now castles short I wanted to
play rook c6 the idea being Queen be a
check King to e7 Queen takes h8 Knight
f3 check king to h1 and Queen to h4
winning yeah longline wrong line but
maybe it is working short castle looks
like our looks insane anyway with Bishop
e3 maybe if it's a simple solution but
if you cannot cancel short what what is
he going to do g3 is also interesting
going form a direct counter attack okay
so maybe I should simply take it just
take it and he retakes with the porn I
think then I can play at least I can
play rook the eighth okay let's let's
get rid of this piece
okay so i still cannot cancel and when I
don't have the direct refutation of all
this okay night f2 but I can just take
it at that castle short actually my
intention was roped the eighth Quincy
five Queen g2 but then long castles is
possible how how to continue it's not
easy a tech g2a can always get along I
don't want that
okay I need to play with down on the
download the clock by quite some some
marginal but okay 25 Quincy too long
castle screen d5 it's a it's a pawn and
probably probably okay for me
in this position there's also a to hang
so it's not them he must pay attention
to to this idea and unclear a 35 cents i
also have queen d6 trying to exchange
the Queen and allow short castle
until caught up on the clock this is osm
always helpful if you're not them down
by a long time okay
mmm yeah rookie one maybe just attacking
I'm the porn how do I am do I keep this
this pawn can try Knight to c6 party
Scott f4 f4 f6 okay but i can't play f6
Bishop g6 check i have king e7 so the
discover check is not down not deadly
okay okay let's take it or take yeah
probably take it King takes I I
completely forgot that's possible
give fo probably somewhat somewhat
annoying about maybe Bishop c6 King c6
fe5 I can play play I can play at five
then try to pick up the pawn still he
needs to take I can take on if I first
this is better maybe okay
try it for rogue age three
check-check
can still play seven
Isis is an almost amazing net but just
almost time morning no way to to
maintain whoops this wasn't intended i
just lost a move here
check-check
so draw it draw at the end and yeah a
bit a bit disappointing I played played
in not precisely a g5 for example just
just winced probably does it win maybe
not not one hundred percent clear if i
look at the g5 here just quickly I know
he's moving the pieces this can oh sorry
I cannot do any comments if he moves the
pieces around quickly yeah thanks for
thanks for watching the game i think it
was was interesting probably spoiled
something along the way thanks for
watching